Jesse, right now you have
four wins under your belt.
You've got $20,000
in your pocket.
You're fighting
for the five grand.
But being that this is your
fifth competition, if you win,
you will also receive
that bonus of $10,000.
Do you want to pick the
weapon, or do you want to pick
the forge welding technique?
I want the weapon.
All right, what
are you thinking?
I'm thinking the
pair of pugio daggers.
Holy cow, what a bold choice.
Pugio was a popular sidearm in
second and third century Rome.
Gladiators were known
to battle with two
pugio, one in each hand.
These close quarter
combat weapons
featured a wide
leaf-shaped blade
to inflict deep lethal
wounds upon an enemy,
both on the battlefield
and inside the walls
of the Colosseum.
However, the pugio is most
well known as the weapon
used to murder Julius Caesar.
John, you've got
a choice to make.
What forge welding
technique do you want
to use to build your daggers?
Let's go with canister, and
we're going to have to use
some bicycle chain in it.
Bicycle chain in
canister Damascus.
All right, very, very tall
order on the plate today.
So good luck, stay sharp.
Your time starts now.
Because this is
my fifth battle,
I'm definitely a
little bit tired.
I've hit that bottom
plateau in terms of energy,
and the only way I can go is up.
I used to forge out
chef's knives at home
in batches of two or three.
So this is a pretty
comfortable zone for me.
I think my canister is
up to temperature now.
I think it's the
perfect time to bring
them over to the squaring dies
and start setting those wells.
Right now, I have
them all forged
to shape, fit to dimension.
Just want to get them
ready for heat treat now.
It's time for le quench.
So I decide to do one at a time.
Oh, we've got a quench.
The temperature of my
first blade looked perfect.
Now, it's time to put
blade two in the fire.
All right, Jesse's
got two blades quenched.
It went perfectly.
There were no warps
in either blade.
It's time to grind these
blades to final dimension.
I slap on a fresh 36 grit
and just start going ham.
But there's still
a few things that I
need to do in this
round, include
finish shaping the handle
and then sharpening it.
I leave myself a lot of time
to sharpen these blades,
because I don't want
to run out of time
and have one edge unsharpened.
So the idea that I've got is
that I'm going to forge the two
knives out of one billet,
and I'm going to stretch
out the tang in the middle.
And I'll cut those in two.
So after I've got them ground,
now it's time to heat treat.
Out of the oil, it looks good.
I think I've got what I want.
That's going to work.
And then I go to the grinder.
The second blade I noticed
a delam on the edge.
I am concerned that another
could show up while I grind.
But I think I've still
got enough width,
and so now, I'm just
going to work that out.
I now have to assemble
these two handles.
It is going to be a big
challenge all the way around.
I know I have to find a handle,
because the clock marches on.
Everything seems
to be just right,
but I glance, and
I'm seeing I've
used up better than an hour.
So I know I've got
to keep moving on.
It's a very complex handle.
I know that I have a lot
of moving parts in this.
I know I'm going to have
to make sure everything
fits properly with it.
What John's doing
is a great idea,
but it's very, very
time consuming.
It's not an easy process,
but I do get them inset some.
After I get the pommel glued
on, then it's to the grinder.
It looks like a
potato on a stick.
It doesn't look great.
And I need to get this
shaped into something
that is functional.
What John's got going on in
his handle, it kind of almost
looks like a dog chew bone.
I still need to
sharpen the blade.
I get it etched.
I'm racing the clock right now.
And I don't have time
to make mistakes today.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, turn off your
machines, put down your tools.
This battle is over.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
The armor, stab, and slash.
Jesse, you're up first.
You ready to go?
I'm ready to go.
I know you love going first.
Yep.
[suspenseful music]
All right, Jesse,
you survived.
Good job.
Your blades look great.
I like the symmetry on these.
They look like a matched pair.
Everything's tight.
Everything's smooth.
Your edges are still good.
You do have a few flat spots,
but there's not enough there
where I can catch a nail on it.
The biggest issue I
have is the handles.
They have no grip
to them whatsoever,
enough so that, with
one of the chops,
I actually caught a knuckle.
It was a knuckle slip up.
Some contouring would
have made it a lot
easier to hold on to them.
But otherwise, great job.
Thank you.
It's always fun being the
second guy, right, John?
Sure, why not?
- You ready to go?
- Absolutely.
All right, let's do it.
[suspenseful music]
All right, John, you survived.
Got to be happy about that.
You've got some
glinting on the edges,
nothing I'm really catching on.
The biggest problem I have,
the contouring you have
on there is basically
the exact opposite
of what I said about Jesse's.
They're not sliding
anywhere, but
they're not comfortable at all.
But, overall, they held
together and nothing came loose.
Edges survived.
Good job.
Thank you.
That handled the forge.
This is the sharpness
test, the banner slice.
Jesse, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
I'm ready.
All right.
[choral music]
All right, Jesse, let's talk
about your matching pugio
daggers here.
That's a beautiful matched set.
They're quite identical,
very close to that.
Now, your edge, your
edges cut nicely,
and overall, your
weapon will cut.
John, your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Yes sir.
- Let's do this.
[suspenseful music]
All right, John, let's talk
about your pugio daggers here.
Your edges are sharp.
It's just that it's got a grind
here that's not razor sharp.
So when cutting with this, there
are some areas in this where
it just got snagged
with the blade,
and it does rip a little bit.
But overall, sir, your
pugio daggers will cut.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, after
eight hours of furious battle
where you guys built
your pugio daggers out
of bicycle chain
canister Damascus,
it is coming down
to a final decision.
Only one of you can
come out of here on top
with the title of
Gladiator of the Forge.
Jesse, if you win, that
will be your fifth win,
and you will have
$35,000 in your pocket.
Now, John, if you win, you'll
stop his winning streak,
get your first Gladiator
of the Forge title,
a check for $5,000, and
the opportunity to go
forward into the next battle.
Our judges have
discussed your blades,
and they made a final decision.
Today's Gladiator
of the Forge is--
Jesse.
You have done it again.
That is five total wins.
John, you brought us
a good pair of blades,
but unfortunately, they
didn't come out on top.
And Jay is going
to tell you why.
John, you did a
great job out there.
You should be definitely
proud of yourself.
We sure as heck enjoyed
watching you work.
But at the end of the day,
the inner grinds on your pugio
daggers weren't as sharp
as your competitor's, as we
saw during the sharpness test.
And you had a great
idea for the handle,
but it kind of went south.
So that's why we're
sending you home.
John, there's no
question you're talented.
I know you had your competitor
here worried for a little bit.
Unfortunately, you didn't
come out on top today.
At this point, I'm going to
have to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
This is just one more
learning experience.
Take your education and
move to the next thing.
Jesse, you are a
five-time champion.
You got another check for five
grand and a bonus of $10,000.
Congratulations.
- Thank you.
[applause]
So right now, I
got to ask again,
do you have enough energy
to go back in the forge
and fight out another battle?
Put me in, coach.
I love it.
All right, man.
I have five titles.
I'm not ready to give up
this seat any time soon.